first things first uh we just passed the
nine year anniversary of your first
professional
mma fight what are your memories from
that first one because i know it can be
pretty anxiety inducing when you're
stepping in there and making your pro
debut
my first mma fight wow it was pretty
awesome
who was that again i'm trying to
remember it was um
a really fun time um and it was really
incredible to be able to represent
transgender athletes even though i
wasn't out yet i knew that at some point
i
possibly could be so yeah
your journey as a transgender athlete
was the main focus of a 2015 documentary
called game face but now you're getting
a
dramatized version of your life in an
upcoming biopic how did this all come
together
wow i just got contacted by mark gordon
pictures
and i think that this is going to be a
really incredible film given that the
the
people who are involved with with mark
gordon pictures these are the same
people who are behind
saving private ryan and grey's anatomy
and
at steve jobs biopic a few years back
they've also got a great writing team
with t cooper and allison glock who uh
allison glock cooper who worked on nbc's
the blacklist and netflix's get down so
it should be a really amazing film how
does that feel for you
to you know a documentary is one thing
but like you're saying you're now having
all these
people with such a wealth of experience
in hollywood
focused on telling a dramatized version
of your story
oh it feels amazing i feel like my story
is finally gonna get out there in a big
way
so i think it's gonna it's gonna be a
lot i'm not sure how it's going to run
maybe it's going to be informative
but it's going to be entertaining and
people are going to get a lot out of it
i think
i know we're still early into the
process but do you have any idea of who
will be playing you and if not do you
have a dream performer in mind
i have no idea who's going to be playing
me and i'll keep the dream performer to
myself for right now
i don't want to speak too much on that
one that's fair
um so obviously you had this
you were the center of a lot of media
attention in sports when you did come
out and you competed a number of times
after coming out as transgender
for those who may not be familiar with
your story though what compelled you to
retire from the sport
um injuries
a lot of that happened um kind of took
me out of the sport i had
um injuries mostly just took me out of
the sport or i would have kept competing
can you touch on that a bit because i
don't think a lot of
casual fans of mixed martial arts
understand the toll it takes on your
body and in mma
even at the top level you're not making
a lot of money
compared to your contemporaries in other
sports right true we don't make a lot of
money
and it takes it takes a lot of wear and
tear on your body
like you know i'm 45 years old right now
and i've got a lot of
a lot of issues so can you touch a
little bit on
what it was like getting into the cage
after you came out as transgender and
we're gonna get to it a little bit later
but obviously there were
segments of the fan base and of other
people in the industry
who were very vocal against you like
that add any extra weight or pressure on
your shoulders when you're out there
competing
yeah a lot of like prominent people were
talking about a bunch of horrible things
you know
the joe rogans the ronda rouseys the
dana whites of the world
you know and they're still seeking to
ban transgender people from mma
as they were then and you know from from
what they said about me in the past i
could have just like
crawled up into a ball and like given up
i could have just stopped competing but
i didn't and i kept competing and
i kept talking about this issue and i'm
going to continue to do it
it it's funny you mentioned those three
names because those are the exact three
names i had written down
um a debate sparked after you came out
right about the physiology of
transgender women competing against
people who were assigned as
female at birth and joe rogan dana white
ronda rousey the rhetoric they used is
this idea of
male bone density and strength and size
that give transgender
women an unfair advantage against their
opponents can you separate the fact from
fiction of those claims
yeah i think people should like turn to
like i mean
people like to ask me about the science
behind trans athletes and i'll tell you
what i know
but it's not like i'm pulling all this
stuff out of thin air and we will source
the scientists who've come out of the
end of the story yeah yeah
but one thing about like people always
say about bone density and stuff like
that
nowhere in the tail of the tape is bone
density
ever ever ever introduced right nobody
ever talks about bone density
and there's bone density differences
between men also
you know and in women also also for
instance
african-american women have more dense
bones than caucasian women do
right and there isn't i don't see anyone
saying that we shouldn't have
african-american women
competing against cisgender women they
have one
on the most most of the time they have
more dense bones than
uh cisgender white men do so
you know we never we never talk about
this and i think it's just bogus for
them to even bring up bone density in
the first place
things like that things like that that
people just
bring out of thin air and just say are
true that we're fighting against
uh joe this will be the last thing on
joe but he recently faced backlash
for making the claim that young healthy
people shouldn't get the covet 19
vaccine he since sort of backtracked and
said that you know
he's not an expert and these are just
opinions that shouldn't be
so heavily weighed prince harry
countered that saying hey when you have
a platform you have a responsibility to
to
use it in an informative way where do
you sort of stand on that issue because
joe was one of these guys who spoke ill
of you and
i find he often takes the stance of like
hey this is just me speaking out should
he speak however he likes no he
shouldn't speak especially on this issue
that's
so important to transgender people and
transgender people's lives just like
coronavirus is important to people's
lives you know
like he's he just brings up these things
and just makes them up
and i think people should pay attention
to what he said that he's not an expert
you know he's not an expert so people
shouldn't be listening to
should take what he says with a grain of
salt
what's your current relationship like
with the sport of mma as an observer or
someone who's involved
well this is a challenging situation for
me
um the current relationship with an mma
i still have a lot of passion for the
sport i like watching it i want to get
back into training it
and everything like that but a lot of
prominent people don't haven't
recognized what i've done like joe rogan
with ronda rousey's and
all that so so
um i don't think the world of the world
of mma is ready to have an intelligent
conversation
about transgender athletes but i'm
willing to have that conversation and
i'm always willing to stand up so
i'd like to hear it um let's let's turn
the
tone a little bit here because you have
now become such an important and
appreciated advocate for transgender
athletes in sports
how have you embraced this opportunity
to be an advocate because
you know no one no one can insist that
you do so this is something that you've
decided to embrace
how has it felt to be an advocate for
both professionals
and young transgender athletes so
honored
to be this this person who is speaking
for transgender athletes inclusion
um yeah really honored and and
and i kind of want this so
yeah i'm glad to hear that